hi everyone and welcome to this Center
for security policy webinar uh part of
our book series we'll be talking with
the author of our latest work uh who
lost Afghanistan uh the great New York
Times best-selling author Robert Spencer
just waiting for a few more people to
filter in uh to the virtual uh audience
room here and then we'll go ahead and
get started
nearly 2500 U.S service members were
killed more than 20 000 service members
were injured 2.3 trillion dollars were
expended and after 20 years of American
military operations the Taliban
government once again governs
Afghanistan and strict adherence to
Sharia law while playing host to
jihadist groups including Al Qaeda
yet there has been at almost every level
of government no public accounting as to
the question who lost Afghanistan who is
responsible uh for this two decades of
foreign policy failure
to help us answer that question today is
Robert Spencer he's the author of a new
book who lost Afghanistan he's also the
director of jihad watch and a Shulman
fellow at the David Horowitz Freedom
Center the author of some 26 books
including New York Times bestsellers the
politically incorrect guide to Islam and
the Crusades and the truth about
Muhammad
Spencer has led seminars on Islam and
Jihad for the FBI the United States
Central Command the United States Army
command and general staff College the
U.S Army's asymmetric Warfare group The
Joint terrorism task force and the
Justice Department's anti-terrorism
advisory Council as well as various
elements of the U.S intelligence
community
so Robert you were there in the very
beginning uh briefing you know members
of the United States Central Command
people that would have to actually go
fight in Afghanistan so we wanted to ask
you
uh just to start off where did the war
go wrong you know some might remember in
the early aftermath uh after September
11th uh the U.S had largely largely
ousted the Taliban from government in
cooperation with the Northern Alliance
and that in just a few weeks
you know some argue the outcome of
Afghanistan was inevitable you get the
sort of graveyards of Empires language
talking about the terrain and the
geography and other people say well the
decision to invade Iraq was what caused
us to lose focus in Afghanistan
otherwise we could have continued our
Victory there but what's your view when
did Afghanistan go wrong
Kyle thanks uh the problem really
started at the beginning
the whole thing was wrongly conceived
when George W bush decided and this was
along around in November 2001 to
continue our presence in Afghanistan
despite the fact that the Taliban had
effectively been defeated it had been
driven from power it had been so
comprehensively defeated as a matter of
fact that bush and others were referring
to it in the past tense at that time as
if it were completely a spent force uh
but bush had the idea that he was going
to transform Afghanistan into a
western-style secular Republic this was
based on an insufficient appreciation of
the hold that Islamic law had over the
minds of the people of Afghanistan an
insufficient understanding of what
Sharia involved and an insufficient
appreciation of how attached the people
were to it Alt ultimately to the
detriment of our 20-year Adventure there
if we had toppled the Taliban
quarantined the place to the extent that
they could not export Jihad terrorists
the way they did in the run-up to 911
then Bush could justifiably have said it
was mission accomplished but the whole
nation building Adventure is where it
all ran off the rails
I think you mentioned a little bit about
the misunderstanding or failure to
understand uh that the Bush
Administration from the very beginning
had when it came to the nature of Afghan
Society and also I think in particular
the nature of the jihadist enemy in
Afghanistan and having gotten that
fundamental question wrong and I think
this is a major premise of the book none
of the decisions the U.S made in
Afghanistan uh from that point on could
ever really go right it's almost like
you know making a bit of a arithmetic
error you know at the beginning of a
complicated math question can you give
us some examples about how this failure
to understand the nature of the Taliban
and its commitment to Sharia led to some
of these strategic mistakes
yeah absolutely you know the Bush
Administration and the Obama
Administration after it and then the
Trump Administration to a lesser degree
and certainly the Biden Administration
they all evaluated Afghanistan according
to their own understanding of what Islam
is and what role it played in Afghan
society and their view of Islam was
heavily colored by what they were being
told by Muslim Brotherhood linked
lobbies in the United States so George W
Bush started the whole thing off on the
wrong foot on September 17th
2001 just six days after 9 11 when he
went to the mosque in Washington DC and
stood there with nihadawad of the Hamas
linked Council on American Islamic
relations one of the foremost
Brotherhood organizations in the United
States of durrahman alamudi who is still
in prison to this day for funding Al
Qaeda but at that time was the head of
the very influential American Muslim
Council and other Muslim leaders and
Bush said of course famously Islam is
peace
and cautioned Americans about
victimizing innocent Muslims which was
certainly true that Americans should not
victimize innocent Muslims but it was a
strange thing to take be the first
takeaway after the 9 11 attack and it
showed that there was a wrong emphasis
and that he was listening to the wrong
people from the beginning So based on
the assumption that Islam was peace we
went into Afghanistan and Bush and his
people assumed that the Afghans would be
happy to have a secular Republic that
they would see no incompatibility
between a secular Republic and Islam and
that that secular Republic would become
kind of a light unto the Islamic World a
sign of what representative democracy
could do for a nation in that region
and so this was marked by a an
exaggerated deference to Sharia
there are as the fact that there are
even women in Afghanistan today who were
standing up and saying we support the
women in Iran who are trying to live
free and without hijab
there are actually women daring to be
brutalized by the Taliban and standing
up for that in Afghanistan today
if the Bush Administration had said that
we stand as we stand in the United
States itself for women's rights for the
equality of Rights of all people before
the law there would have been many
Afghans who would have flocked to our
side as a refuge but instead we set up
this government in Afghanistan the
Karzai ghani government that was a
Sharia based government and the
Constitution that we developed for
Afghanistan
imposes Sharia and so the Afghan people
could say well we have we can get Sharia
with American occupation or we can get
Sharia without American occupation and
they chose Sharia without American
occupation which was anybody could have
seen that coming
meanwhile their misapprehension of Islam
led to all kinds of errors in the way
that the war was executed for example
when uh there were rumors about qurans
being desecrated by American troops the
general the Commanding General at the
time this is along around 2011. uh
issued this groveling video an
embarrassing video it's still available
on YouTube General John Allen saying uh
I want to apologize to the noble people
of Afghanistan that the Quran was
desecrated and we hold it in the highest
respect and we would never do this
intentionally and so on and so on and
you can understand why they were trying
to pacify the situation but they're
looking at it with a mindset of the West
rather than understanding how that would
appear in Afghanistan as groveling
weakness that was to be exploited rather
other than as a gesture of Goodwill that
should be reciprocated in kind
and that's there are so many other
examples of this type that show that the
the
as you say that the the they got the
first math problem wrong and so
everything built on that was wrong
afterwards
sure and that's the same General John
Allen who is now immersed in a uh
foreign influence Scandal uh with
related to The Brookings Institute
taking money from the government to
Qatar so you can see how these things
sort of followed us home a little bit
and you made it you made a point uh in
the book that I think is worth noting
when you talk about the fact that there
would have been people in Afghanistan
that would have supported a sort of
full-throated American
uh view
um and you say you know one of the
things that the Bush Administration was
trying to do was avoid having uh a sort
of religious Uprising or religious
Awakening all across the Muslim World
Turning against the United States
and you say well in fact there's no
reason to believe that would have
happened because each of the governments
and ruling in each different Muslim
states would have had to come to their
own conclusions about what their best
interests were and many of them may have
sided with us against jihadists and
ironically of course that's what we saw
happen uh under the Trump Administration
with the Abraham Accords where you had
countries like Saudi Arabia the United
Arab Emirates start to make decisions
about the way they would interact with
the United States and with Israel and
other members of the region based on
their on their own national interests
exactly and so if we had pursued
excuse me the same policy in Afghanistan
there's no doubt that uh there would
have been some significant level of
support to assume that uh uh everyone in
Afghanistan thought the same way and
especially that everyone Afghan in
Afghanistan adhered to this fantasy
version of sharia and Islam that the
Bush Administration and later Obama and
Biden embraced it's it's ridiculous but
uh this is where we were you know
another example of how damaging it was
is the number of green on Blue attacks
that is the attacks by Afghan Army and
police Personnel who were being trained
by the Americans and then they turn on
their trainers and kill them and this
happened we don't actually even know
because it's likely that the full number
was covered up but there are hundreds of
such incidents and it all comes once
again from a misapprehension of what we
were dealing with if the Bush
Administration in the beginning had
undertaken a thoroughgoing study of
Islam as the Taliban understood it even
leaving aside the question of May maybe
the Taliban gets Islam all wrong okay
you could even leave open that
possibility
and still understand what the Taliban is
all about and it was criminal
dereliction of Duty that this was not
done but if they had done it they would
have come upon the idea that Muhammad
the prophet of Islam allowed for lying
between a husband and a wife to pacify a
relationship at home and also in Wartime
and he said war is deceit so the Taliban
had every reason based on their own
governing assumptions to send people
into the Afghan National Army and police
to be trained by the Americans and wait
for their chance to kill Americans but
we never took account of that
possibility in any way shape or form
because it would have been islamophobic
to do so and that was job one to avoid
islamophobia
and I think uh you saw some of the
double think that this policy created
when after a green on Blue attack they
would uh they would say well it was
really due to cultural factors and then
you would say oh really what kind of
cultural factors are those and they
wouldn't have an answer
um but I want to you you mentioned
islamophobia and I want to get into this
a little bit about how this
um
how the U.S policy was influence on this
side you know we gave your bio we saw
that you know you briefed multiple
government organizations about the
nature of Islamic law about Jihad about
why it matters when you're addressing
Islamic addressing Islamic terrorism so
there must have been a time when
elements in the U.S government
understood this enough to know that it
was worth learning so what kind of
reception did you get in the early days
of the war on terror uh when you started
to teach this stuff and when did it
start to change and why
Kyle in the early days there was a lot
of receptiveness uh a lot of people in
the uh various government agencies and
in the military when I spoke on military
bases they would say that what I was
telling them made sense of what they had
experienced themselves while serving in
Afghanistan or Iraq
and I heard that many times but what
happened was that there was always
opposition within the various agencies
and the various military organ military
uh
apparatuses that had me speak these uh
there was never
a general acceptance there was always
pushback and the pushback ultimately
proved to be better connected and better
organized and better funded than I was
uh and so what happened ultimately was
that in 2010
or 11
the uh Muslim Advocates Group which is a
Muslim Brotherhood linked
attorneys organization in the United
States along with 57 Muslim and South
Asian organizations including the major
organizations of the Muslim Brotherhood
Network in the United States the Council
on American Islamic relations the
Islamic Society of North America all
those they wrote a letter for hanakhira
of Muslim Advocates signed it but it was
also co-signed by all these groups they
uh wrote a letter to John Brennan who of
course was later the head of the CIA but
at that time was in the Department of
Homeland Security and they demanded that
I'd be fired uh by name I was kind of
flattered that they noticed but at the
same time it was clear what was
happening they demanded that I'd be
removed as a trainer for military and
the FBI and jttf and so on and that all
mentioned of Islam and Jihad and Sharia
and any related matter be removed from
all counter-terror training
and Brennan immediately wrote back and
he not only wrote back he wrote back on
White House stationary
now it's not as if John Brennan's office
didn't have its own stationery and he
had to go down to the white house and
borrow some of Barack Obama's what
Brennan was signaling was that what he
was saying had the approval of the
president
and
what he said was that of course I would
be removed as a trainer and all mention
of Islam and Jihad would be removed from
counter-terror training and it was
and it's never been returned ever since
and this has had a number of results
in Afghanistan it had the result of
hamstringing anyone's ability to do what
we were just talking about a few minutes
ago to understand the Taliban on its own
terms
because to get too close to get too deep
into
what the Taliban said itself that it was
all about what it was up to what its
motives and goals were
it had to get you into areas that the US
government was committed not to going
into
and so it was a dangerous territory for
any military analyst or anybody in the
intelligence Community because they
could be facing reprimands from their
own superiors if they discussed these
issues so the U.S was essentially blind
willfully Blind by its own hand in
Afghanistan in making blah Blythe
assumptions that these people had the
same priorities the same Outlook the
same desires as Western secular
post-christians have
uh and there was no basis for that and
there were a number of ways in which
that was not so but this was something
that the U.S government did not dare to
examine
I want to address that but first I want
to remind folks because I neglected to
do so in the beginning uh we will have a
question and answer period uh in the
last 15 minutes or so of the
presentation you should see a q a tab at
the bottom uh of your screen and that's
where you'll type in your question and
then we'll pick some of the best
questions we can find uh for Robert at
the end
but Robert I want you see you talked
about how we were willfully blind uh and
the the time period where this happened
the 2010-2011 time period I think is
interesting because that's also the
period where we started to shift in
Afghanistan to talk about negotiating
with the Taliban we opened negotiation
with the Taliban uh not under President
Trump president Trump got a lot of
criticism for his negotiation with
Taliban but the reality is we were
negotiating with the Taliban uh very
early on way back way back in in the
2011 time period under Barack Obama
and so we were entering into negotiation
with the Taliban with assumptions about
what the Taliban wanted uh and believed
that were never true and we saw this
play out even you know as we were
leaving Afghanistan where you had you
know the U.S negotiators would say well
you have to have a diverse government uh
that respects the rights of women and
the Taliban negotiator would say yes uh
women will have all the rights that they
have under Sharia
and the U.S negotiator would say great
foreign
there of how how this error followed us
all the way through uh you know really
from beginning to end but reminding
people that that negotiation with the
Taliban and the idea that uh
instead of forming a secular Republic in
Afghanistan and we can talk about the
relevance of that we mentioned a little
bit whether that was even possible but
they began very quickly to accept the
notion of sort of an islamist Republic
for Afghanistan and an islamist Republic
that the Taliban would be would be a
part of
I mean do you think that that some of
these internal
um pressures that you talked about
played a role in that in that change of
of goal very much so Kyle the fact is
that the negotiations themselves
manifest the same misunderstanding and
the same willful blindness because if
they had studied here again
what the Taliban believed about Islam
and still believes for that matter I
still think that it's very likely that
we could go down and walk it through the
state department today and not find
anybody in there not even one person who
has any idea what the Taliban really
believes and what they want
and the fact is if they had studied it
they would know they would have known in
2010 and 2011
that under Islamic law you only enter
into negotiations with a non-muslim foe
under two circumstances one is if that
non-muslim foe looks as if it is about
to convert to Islam
and the second one is if you are losing
if you are losing and you need time to
gather strength to fight again more
effectively in the future those are the
only two circumstances under which it is
permitted according to the Islamic law
that the Taliban follows to conclude a
deal a truce with an Infidel enemy and
so the state department the defense
department the administrations involved
should have thought
when the Taliban is willing to negotiate
the Taliban is telling us they're losing
because they don't think we're about to
convert to Islam
and so that's not
what's that I said let's hope not
not yet anyway so in
taking that one off the table the only
other option is that the Taliban wants
to negotiate because they're losing so
that would have been the time if they
had understood that to press forward
even harder to final Victory and maybe
really to obliterate this organization
but instead they thought oh great isn't
that wonderful they want peace just like
we want peace and so let's negotiate
without realizing that the Taliban had
just told them by the very fact of the
negotiations themselves that they were
in a position of weakness
and so the position of weakness was not
capitalized upon and instead they were
invited in as you noted invited into the
governing Coalition and ended up
ultimately back in power in Afghanistan
and let's talk a little bit about that
uh ultimate withdrawal from Afghanistan
that those last couple of years I mean
one of the things I think worth pointing
out was in the the folks at long Ward
Journal have talked about this and the
Taliban to begin with was gaining power
in the provinces they'd control the
number of provinces over the years uh
getting closer and closer to to Kabul in
2020 in part because the United States
while it was negotiating with the
Taliban was not attacking them and had
created uh Rules of Engagement to
prevent our forces uh from from
targeting uh targeting them while while
we were negotiating so that is sort of
the lead up to this ultimate withdrawal
from Afghanistan and little question of
course that the withdrawal itself was
badly bungled uh we had billions of
dollars in equipment lost we had
American citizens left behind in
Afghanistan and of course you had those
uh American soldiers killed in an ISIS
attack uh in part because the U.S had
surrendered control of security for
Kabul to the Taliban so my question
Robert Spencer is who should be held
responsible for that failure
well the failure in regard to the
withdrawal is squarely the fault of the
Biden Administration so the president
himself although nobody really thinks
the president is the one calling the
shots in this Administration uh but the
president himself should be held
responsible as well as the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Mark milley above all
uh and the people who are telling the
president what he what he should do and
should not do
um all of them
ordinarily should be held accountable
but none of them will be or have been
because of course the very people who
should be holding them accountable are
in the same
uh on the same side so what you have in
the withdrawal
is the culmination of all the false
assumptions and wrong-headed Analysis
that had led to us being there 20 years
to start with
compounded by the American military's
new attention on enforcing ideological
Conformity within its own ranks and so
all through the summer of 2021 we had
the U.S military having critical race
Theory seminars and things like that uh
in in instead of obviously formulating a
coherent plan for withdrawal from
Afghanistan and so when it came to be
time to withdraw
the Biden Administration closed Bagram
Air Base in the dark of night and forced
everybody to go to the commercial
airport which was setting up for all the
disasters that happened as a result of
that if they had kept the air base open
and they could have gotten all the
civilians there
safely and gotten them out of the
country safely and then gotten the
military out of the country safely to to
close Bagram Air Base first was just an
indication that what we have with
General Millie's and Joe Biden's
military is a woke distracted force that
is not concerned with what it ought to
be concerned with and is instead
concerning itself with all these issues
that really have nothing to do with what
the military's mission is and ought to
be
I I think this is an important point and
people may Wonder well what is this
question of wokeness in the military
have to do with you know the debate over
Afghanistan or the inability of of the
government and the military to talk
about the nature of Islam and Jihad but
I think it has a lot to do with it
because during this 20-year period of
fighting in Afghanistan you had a DOD
that was increasingly inwardly focused
on managing what its own people thought
and what its own people believed uh and
and so now you have uh now you have you
know chairman Millie talking about
um you know reading about white rage and
and and that Corruption of the general
officer Corps
uh because you had that that
establishment that uh of a
politicization of what the military and
what its members had to believe and to
say
absolutely and that really started on
September 17 2001 when George W bush
said Islam is peace and that was not
just an offhand quip or an attempt to
mollify our Muslim allies but something
that became a Cornerstone of American
policy and so that was the first real
large-scale exercise in telling our
military personnel what to think and so
the uh military people who brought me in
and others like me who spoke honestly
about the ideological roots of the
threat we were facing and what we were
up against in Afghanistan and Iraq
they were under pressure immediately
for not Towing the ideological line of
the administration and this is something
that never should have happened in the
United States of America
but once that precedent was set then it
was easy to build upon it as we see how
wokeness and this leftist agenda in the
military has so quickly become something
that is taken for granted that it must
be enforced and this is the the fruit of
setting a precedent the the the the
precedent was set in the first decade of
this Century that the military would be
the arena for the enforcement of an
ideological uh lockstep imposed from
above and that was that and now once
it's been done it's always easier to do
it the second time and third time and
fourth time
right and I think the the other place
where this uh this took place was in the
uh transitioning of language where
instead of talking about jihadists and
Islamic terrorists we started to talk
about extremists and countering
extremism and this then made it possible
to create an environment where an
extremist was an extremist for any
number of things including things uh
that you know the American people
consider you know very normal and
mainstream uh most recently you know
most recently complaining at your local
school board meeting
um and and I don't think enough people
understand
uh when this change in in our Focus took
place but it was during this period and
it was partially uh due to this need to
control what you couldn't couldn't say
uh about Jihad and and our our conflict
with Islamic terrorism yeah actually
yeah
the the countering violent extremism
program of the Obama Administration
which was the Obama administration's
counter-terror program actually began in
2011.
and that was the program that was put in
place when all mention of Islam and
Jihad was removed from counter-terror
training what replaced it was this
amorphous violent extremism that was
never defined in any of the government's
literature about the terror threat which
just opened the door for the way that
it's being misused now to that anybody
can be called an extremist and now
enemies of the administration that are
its legitimate political opposition are
being branded with this label this that
this is another ball that has was
started rolling in the uh controversy
over what exactly we were dealing with
in Afghanistan and Iraq
I think that I think that's right
continuing on the theme of The Afghan
withdrawal one thing the Afghan
withdrawal did achieve uh was to bring
in large number of Afghan refugees now
initially we were told that the
withdrawal was focused on removing
American citizens from Afghanistan it
was focused on uh removing those Afghans
who had worked very closely with our
military and our government people like
military interpreters and the like
uh and that everyone who was being
evacuated from Afghanistan was being
very closely vetted and very heavily
vetted and of course it turned out later
that in fact none of that was true that
uh American citizens and uh what are
called special interest visas were not
being prioritized in fact uh what was
being prioritized was bringing in the
maximum number of uh Afghan refugees
possible and that there had been almost
no vetting taking place
how should we think about this
um this element of the withdrawal Robert
the Biden administrations uh seemingly
willful uh deportation of large numbers
of unvetted Afghan migrants at the
expense of American citizens this is yet
another betrayal of the American people
by the Biden Administration the Afghans
who were brought in uh some counts are
that they were up to 124 000 of them
uh the Department of Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayorkas has
admitted that they were not vetted the
vast majority of them were not vetted
and those that were vetted were vetted
against criminal and terrorist databases
that we have of Afghan people but those
are just lists of names
and the there was a Brisk business and
false identifications in Kabul toward
the end of our presence there and so
it's not even certain that the people
who were vetted were really vetted in
other words they're not the people they
claim to be so they weren't really
screened at all of course the
administration would never dare to try
to ascertain from actual questioning of
these people what their attitudes and
assumptions are regarding Islamic Jihad
regarding Sharia and so on because here
again that would be islamophobic but
we're bringing in now we've brought in
now this large population of people from
a culture that is vastly different from
American culture now a lot of people
will object to that and say America has
always been a Melting Pot always been a
place where people from many cultures
have come you yourself are the children
of immigrants and so on and so on and
therefore you have nothing to say about
this but
insufficient attention here again is
being paid to the fact that Afghan
culture is not quite as different as or
is actually far more different from
American culture than say uh polish or
Italian or even Algerian or Moroccan
culture uh Afghan culture in the first
place is strongly based on Islamic
tenets that include
things like the uh sexual abuse of
children child marriage the sexual abuse
of young boys in particular uh and these
things even it's it's a terrible Scandal
among one among many that the American
government was aware of all this during
our presence in Afghanistan and actually
ordered American Personnel not to give
our punitive Afghan allies trouble if
they for were for example molesting a
little boy or something like that
because it was their culture but now
they're here and we have already had
several of the migrants arrested for
spousal abuse which is taken for granted
as acceptable in Afghanistan sexual
abuse of children
including young boys and so on this kind
of thing was entirely foreseeable
but here again nobody even in the
refugee resettlement apparatus is paying
any attention to it because to do so
would be islamophobic and so we are
setting these people down in American
communities many of whom are essentially
ticking time bombs and American people
are going to be victimized
but no one can talk about it and no one
can do anything about it
all right I remember there was an
article that came out from oh I forget
what what the publication was but it was
bio a woman who had worked in Refugee
centers in Europe
and uh you know during the quote-unquote
Syrian migration crisis but of course
many of them were not actually syrians
at all they were coming from all over
the world including from Afghanistan and
she said even uniquely among that
population the Afghans were particularly
hard to try to assimilate they just
that's where they got large numbers of
sexual assaults and and other other
issues
um and and you know this was someone who
was not predisposed to this opinion this
was this was what she learned by dealing
with with the population and and of
course to even mention these kinds of
things was completely unacceptable uh
nor could you mention the fact that they
were being brought to military bases and
then they were freely allowed to leave
there was nothing you could do to keep
them there uh until they had been vetted
and so yeah Robert I appreciate your
your handling that issue because it's an
issue that people don't really want to
talk about but I think it's it's
important
and of course also there's also the
possibility if not the likelihood that
we brought over some Taliban and Isis
guys
because here again war is deceit
if you've got deception at the heart of
your military approach
and then you've got a power that you
consider to be hostile
offering free passage to people who want
to come into the United States
it you'd be stupid not to take advantage
and they're not stupid
and so I think it's it's virtually
certain that we brought jihadis over
here who intend to victimize American
people and unfortunately we're only
going to know that for sure when it
happens
right I remember I think it was last
year there was an alert that went out in
Alexandria Virginia uh regarding
concerns that that there were um
jihadist terrorists who had uh were part
of the the evacuation flights and were
now you know apparently targeting a mall
or something like that nothing ever came
of it but it was it was suddenly
shocking to see the admission that oh
yeah this might be a real problem and of
course there there were British
intelligence assessments of uh Taliban
and Al Qaeda people being picked up and
Isis people being picked up as part of
these flights and several in the United
States as well
yes and yet nothing nobody is talking
about this in the Public Square it seems
as if uh and nobody wants to handle the
political implications of what that
might mean everyone is preferring just
to whistle in the dark and hope for the
best and that's really how it's been
since as as the book shows that's how
it's been since 2001 and how the entire
Afghanistan misadventure was handled
foreign so obviously we've talked about
the failure in Afghanistan uh what led
up to it uh 20 years really of refusing
to recognize the nature of the enemy we
were dealing with uh obviously the
failure of Afghanistan has told us
something larger about the viability of
nation-building uh in the Muslim world
but I wonder Robert in a in a world
today where many people have taken their
eyes off of the Middle East they've
taken their eyes off of the nature of
the jihadist threat or terrorism in
general
uh but is there a larger National
Security lesson that we can draw out of
our 20 years in Afghanistan uh in your
view that we should be we should be
focused on in you know it moving forward
Kyle I suppose the answer there is and
what you were saying about the uh fact
that we most Americans think that this
is all over that the Jihad threat is
something that we had to be concerned
about in the wake of the 9 11 attacks
but they got lucky that day and they're
not going to get lucky again we have
nothing really to be concerned about
uh the Persistence of the Taliban the
fact that it did not die when so much
pressure was brought to bear upon it but
it was able to rally and ultimately
retake power is an indication of the
Persistence of the Islamic jihadis a few
years back I wrote a book called the
history of jihad that really is a 1400
year record of that persistence and it
shows that when jihadis did suffer a
loss and a setback they never in in any
instance gave up and said well okay it's
all over we won't wage Jihad anymore
they just uh abided their time gathered
their strength waited out the Foe and
struck again when the times were
propitious
this is a lesson that nobody in the
American public sphere seems to have
learned from this entire Affair uh but
the fact that there are Taliban
operatives running the government in
Afghanistan today is living proof that
it's true and that the Jihad threat
continues unfortunately because of so
many domestic policies it's actually
greater in the United States than was in
the aftermath of 9 11 and on we're going
to find that out one day one way or
another
Robert thank you uh let's now turn to q
a we've got a couple of uh a couple of
good questions in our q a uh chat and uh
if you as we go through these if you
think of one please feel free to go
ahead and put your your question in as
well we'll do as many as we have time
for let me start off with this question
uh years ago the question reads the US
Army published area guides for each
country they were not ideological and
offered a pretty good assessment of
culture and ethnicity Etc
is our intelligency and not capable now
of presenting realistic information
rather than magical thinking from our
leaders Robert are we capable of doing
this
I don't think so uh I've seen some of
the area guides that were published in
recent years and while they they still
have useful details and all kinds of
helpful information for getting along
day to day in a given area they don't
contain now you noted in the question
that they were not ideological to start
with but nowadays when ideology is
playing such an important role
in countries such as Afghanistan in the
way that we ought to approach countries
such as Afghanistan we're leaving our
troops completely ill-equipped to deal
with many many things that they might
encounter there and I remember uh
speaking to military personnel on many
occasions about their time in
Afghanistan and Iraq and how it was a
Common Thread universally that they were
not equipped
for what they saw
and they weren't told how to understand
what they saw and so much of what they
saw was justified in Islamic law but
this was never discussed by the people
who were training them and sending them
into these places in the first place so
yeah I would say our Intelligentsia now
is simply not capable of presenting
realistic information there needs to be
a complete change at the top and a
transformation in the thinking in the
defense department and the state
department and the complete sweeping out
of the main what is mainstream thinking
today in favor of a more uh courageous
realism that doesn't bow to political
correctness and uh political
considerations here at home but just
assesses things as they are
uh next question is about the abrupt
pull out and they ask with the pull out
last year and the abandonment of ammo
and vehicles weapons and planes how much
danger does that really pose to the
American people or or other allies in
the region I mean do we have to be
worried Robert about a Taliban uh that
is now well equipped with arms
uh yeah actually we do Kyle
um you know I saw so many people saying
oh it doesn't matter uh it's a shame
that all that was left there but they
don't know how to use it
well you know the Taliban they don't
exist in a vacuum and the Chinese they
know how to use all those things and
they're happy to step in they've already
stepped in in many ways economically
they're happy to step in and train them
not long ago there was a helicopter
accident a U.S Blackhawk helicopter went
down as Taliban Personnel were operating
it and here again the the news was
greeted with ridicule and people saying
see they don't know how to use these
things and uh it is if it's some sort of
comic Opera uh situation but these guys
well you know there are there are
accidents when Americans are training
also
and the fact that the accident happened
in itself is an indication that the
Taliban are training to use the material
we left behind and that is going to have
effects in Pakistan in India
uh maybe even elsewhere as well but the
Taliban have already announced their
intentions of exporting their Jihad and
we gave them the means to do so
I I want to ask this question uh or
really it's kind of a comment because it
gets to something we talked about
earlier says my son an officer in the
Army served in Afghanistan and in Syria
he observed that soldiers on the ground
while tactically successful were cynical
about the overall nature of their
mission uh while first premises are
wrong it's hard to find the right Road
our leaders are woke and foolish I
wanted to read that comment because I
wanted to get to this Robert how do we
distinguish between
the everyday soldier that serves in
Afghanistan served in Iraq have served
in the other places in the global war on
terror that we asked them to serve and
the leadership that we're criticizing
here uh right because I think I think we
do need to make a distinction there
did was everybody clueless or did some
people who were a little bit closer to
the fire understand what was going on
and they were badly served by their
leadership you know Kyle to a man when I
spoke to military personnel who served
in Afghanistan and Iraq they knew
exactly what they were dealing with and
they were deeply frustrated and often
quite angry with the leadership that
hamstrung their ability to counter the
foe that they met in Afghanistan and
Iraq and this was not a failure of the
American Military this was a failure of
the civilian leadership and the military
leadership but not a failure of the rank
and file military personnel every time
the American Military met the Taliban
in Afghanistan and were allowed to fight
they won
the Americans did
but they were so restricted
and so poorly LED
by the American leadership that those
victories were all together too few and
ultimately we ended up losing the whole
thing
but uh the American Military has nothing
to the American military personnel who
served in Afghanistan and Iraq had
nothing to be ashamed of they could have
brought both to a successful conclusion
but were not allowed to by their
leadership
uh a question about the motives of our
leadership uh his fellow says hello and
thank you Mr Spencer for your continued
instruction over the years my question
is uh was it feigned night naivete from
the former President Bush about the
nature uh of Islam and Jihad or is it
possible that he had some other
strategic purpose or some other uh
intention in laying laying this
groundwork for uh
the American understanding of Islam
near as it can be discerned it seems as
if President Bush was trying to ensure
that our allies in the Islamic World
notably Saudi Arabia would not be
incensed by his framing of the conflict
but would be able to join in the
conflict on their own terms without
believing that they were compromising
something that was near and dear to them
and that's all well and good if it had
just remained on the level of rhetoric
and not interfered with the ability of
our military and intelligence agencies
to evaluate the threat to understand it
properly and then to deal with it
adequately but it did and so
you you don't have to say that he had
some nefarious intent
in doing this he had every good
intention of trying to keep this from
coming to be a wider war with maybe the
entire Islamic World which would have
been a massive World War uh but as it
turned out because of this
thank you
ended up handicapping our efforts in the
ways that we've discussed in this
webinar so far
um here's a question I think is is
useful we talked a little bit about some
of the the wages of this failure uh this
question is have we learned our lesson
or will we lose Africa in the near
future as well uh what is the state of
the Jihad in the world now Robert uh
what are the main major battlefields
this questioner asks about Africa in
particular
um but have we learned our lesson and
where where are the current Jihadi
battlefields that that matter Kyle in
the first place when the Islamic State
Isis was driven out of Iraq and Syria uh
by the Trump Administration it regrouped
in Africa primarily in three areas or
two areas uh West Africa Nigeria in
particular where the Boko Haram group a
Jihad group that has been operating
there for many years uh rebranded itself
or a faction of it rebranded itself as
the Islamic State West Africa Province
and uh really it's been quite
extraordinary because they have
been able to
essentially with impunity gain control
over a large part of the northern part
of the country and expand their
operations out into the surrounding
countries Niger Cameroon Burkina Faso
and others meanwhile there's another
Islamic State affiliate in Mozambique
that has taken control of the northern
province of Cabo Delgado which is uh the
site of some very important oil wells
and so that has very serious
implications the third is not an Isis
affiliate but an Al-Qaeda affiliate in
Somalia
and they also are acting with essential
impunity at this point and so you have
West Africa East Africa and South Africa
all very powerful and growing Jihad
groups and so that could mean that
you'll see a recrudescence of the Isis
caliphate in Africa and meanwhile have
any lessons been learned no lessons have
been learned nothing has been learned in
Washington the same people who are
responsible for the catastrophe in
Afghanistan are still in power
they're still making policy and they're
still making policy based on all their
false assumptions that led to the
debacle in Afghanistan so that means
it's likely to recur in Africa and
elsewhere
I excellent summation of where we stand
now I want to ask this last question it
will be our last question because I
think it's a good question to end on
uh what would victory in Afghanistan
have looked like
what should it have looked like
well you know I kind of touched on that
briefly at the beginning saying that if
we had uh quarantined the place if we
had bombed the al-Qaeda training camps
put them out of commission and prevented
jihadis from leaving Afghanistan maybe
that would have involved preventing
anyone from leaving Afghanistan and then
you know people would say oh this is
terrible you can't do this and their
human rights considerations and so on
unfortunately in Wartime you have to
make some hard choices if we had done
that
then I think that's the best kind of
Victory we could have hoped for we can't
transform Afghan society and make it
into Cleveland Ohio it's never going to
happen and we shouldn't have spent a
trillion how many however many trillions
and 20 years and 2500 American lives
trying to do that
we should have prevented Afghanistan
from taking its Jihad outside
Afghanistan and that would have been
Victory enough
thank you Robert Spencer uh thanks to
our audience today I do want to uh
remind them or let them know that
Robert's book who lost Afghanistan is
available on amazon.com
um you can find it either by uh looking
up Robert's name or looking up uh our
name the center for security policy and
status for security policy pressed on
Amazon it could come right up
um it was doing pretty well in the
counterterrorism uh section of of
Amazon's rankings the last time I
checked and we'd be very grateful if
folks would uh go ahead and get a copy
and if they find it valuable leave us a
five-star review uh we thank you for
your attendance today Robert Spencer
thank you very much uh for helping us
look at this question who lost
Afghanistan thank you Kyle much
appreciated
all right thank you everyone stay tuned
uh and check out
securefreedom.org
securefreedom.org if you enjoyed this
webinar and you'd like to see more of
what we are up to uh both in our
writings uh and in our webinar webinars
and um thank you so much
this has been the center for security
policy
I'm Kyle scheidler